We're now going to look at a pair
of cases, CAS v CAS from New York,
an AC versus Bz from Massachusetts.
In both of these cases,
courts had to decide what could happen
with cryogenically frozen embryos left
over from infertility treatments
after a couple had gotten divorced.
The basic story is the same in both cases.
In each case,
a couple suffered from infertility and
decided to use in vitro fertilization in
order to try to have children.
Before we go any further,
it's worth having a basic understanding
how in vitro fertilization or IVF works.
First doctors collect sperm from the man
in eggs from a woman in the latter case
with a minor surgery.
Physicians then combine the eggs and
sperm forming what the courts in these
opinions call pre embryos or
pre zygotes several days later,
some of those pre zygotes
or then implanted into a
woman's uterus in hopes of a
successful pregnancy,
the woman receiving the implant can be
the same woman as the egg donor or a
surrogate.
In our cases,
the woman receiving the pre
zygotes was the egg donor.
One of the intended parents,
any pre zygotes that are leftover can
be cryogenically frozen for later use
before any of this took place.
The two couples in our two cases filled
out consent forms where they specified
what should happen to any cryogenically
frozen embryos should various events
occur.
For example,
if the couple's decided they no longer
wanted children or if the couple is
passed away.
In particular,
these forums specified what should
happen if they separated or got divorced.
The cast is said that the zygotes should
be used for scientific research while
AC and busies consent forms specified
that Bz should get control of
cryogenically frozen zygotes.
In each case,
the ex wife wishes to use the
frozen embryos after the divorce,
while the ex husband does not wish to
become a father in the cast as case from
New York.
This goes against the couple's wishes as
expressed on their consent form and in
an agreement they wrote up
at the time of their divorce,
which affirmed that the zygotes where to
go to scientific research in AAC versus
Bz case.
This seems to accord with the wishes that
the couples indicated that the couple
indicated on their medical consent form
and there is no ladder documentation in
both cases.
The question is can one parent and forced
the medical consent forms against the
other in cast versus cast?
Steven CAS is attempting to enforce
their agreement that the embryos would go
for scientific research against his ex
wife Maureen cass who wishes to try and
have them implanted in AC versus Bz.
Bz wishes to enforce the consent forms
against her ex husband a z in order to
get control of the
cryogenically frozen vials
in her opinion and cast versus cast.
Chief Justice k looks at the case like
a typical contract case in which the
court's goal is to ascertain what the
parties agreed to and then to enforce
their agreement.
Just because they involve a sensitive
subject does not mean they should not
quote generally be presumed valid and
binding unquote just as other similar
agreements are.
In fact,
the chief justice things
that these sort of quote,
advanced directives unquote are especially
important in emotionally sensitive
domains such as personal matters of
reproductive choice involved in this case
since they can prevent
litigation by making it clear
what the individuals wanted
before the conflict emerged.
Written agreements make it possible for
courts to seek to honor the parties.
Expressions of choice made
before disputes erupt.
The court of Appeals For New York
therefore ruled for the ex husband and
prevented the ex wife from attempting
to become pregnant using the frozen
embryos against the couple's agreement
that the embryos would go to research
should they get divorced.
Justice Cowan writing for the Supreme
Judicial Court of Massachusetts in AC
versus BZ starts out in the same vein
looking at this as just an ordinary
contract.
She recites five different reasons why
the consent forms are likely unenforcable
as a against the ex husband.
The consent form was an agreement
between the couple and the clinic,
but did not say it was meant to form an
agreement between the two members. Uh,
of the couple that consent form do not
indicate for how long a period of time
they are intended to apply.
There is no definition of the term
separated in the consent form,
so it is not clear when it applies and
on all occasions except the first the
husband's signed the consent form,
what was still blank and then the wife
filled in all the details including the
instruction that she was to get
control of the frozen embryos.
The consent form is also
not a separation agreement,
so it is not enforceable between
the ex husband and the ex wife,
but this is not justice
Collins main argument.
Even if this agreement
were perfectly executed,
it would not be enforceable
as against public policy.
The justice is quote,
would not enforce an agreement that would
compel one to become a parent against
his or her will unquote just as Cowan
reads other aspects of Massachusetts
family law to indicate a general policy
by the state legislature that quote,
individuals should not be
bound by certain agreements,
binding them to enter or not enter
into familial relationships unquote.
She sees this principle at work in the
fact that parents cannot contract and
advanced to give their children up for
adoption in courts reluctance to enforce
agreements that for surrogate mothers to
give up their children they bear and in
their refusal to enforce contracts
requiring an individual to a band in a
marriage.
Justice Cowan here is announcing
more than a default rule,
an individual cannot by contract wave
for later decision whether to become a
parent.
The justice then applies the
broad principle that quote
individuals shall not be
compelled to enter into an intimate family
relationships and that the law shall
not be used as a mechanism for forcing
such relationships when they're not
desired unquote to the case at hand and
finds that the ex wife cannot use the
frozen vials since that would force her
ex husband to become a father coat over
his president.
Objections unquote.
The big difference between how the two
cases come out therefore appears to be
that in cast versus cas,
the agreement would have prevented
parenthood while an AC versus Bz.
The agreement would have
forced parenthood on one party,
but we can easily imagine arguments for
applying the general principle of cast
to ac and BC as well.
And he's Enbz may have thought through
very carefully at the time exactly what
they wanted and decided ex ante that
the best option was for BZ to keep the
vials.
There's an asymmetry here where courts
will protect parties from themselves when
they have been agreed in advance.
Not to become parents,
but not when they have given.
When they have agreed in advance that
one we'll have a right to force a
parenthood on the other.
Okay,
so let's go to a quiz.
A couple began IVF several years
ago and there are several vials of
cryogenically frozen embryos leftover.
The couple initially specified in their
consent form that the husband would get
control of the vials if they got divorced.
Now the couple has divorced and the ex
husband wants to have the frozen embryos
implanted in a surrogate mother.
The X, Y Sue's to stop him.
For whom? What a Massachusetts court
rule. The ex husband or the ex wife.
Okay.
Well,
a Massachusetts court following a z
versus BZ would rule for the ex wife.
In this case the ex husbands action would
make her apparent against her will and
so the forms they claim to give him
the right to do this are unenforceable.
Surrogacy contracts race similar,
thorny,
ethical and public policy questions.
These contracts attempt to govern the
procreative choices of the surrogate after
implantation.
Surrogacy provisions routinely give
intended parents the right to force
surrogates to terminate pregnancies.
If quote a fetus suffers from a serious
birth defect or if a multiple pregnancy
occurs where the fetal reduction may be
recommended to improve the outcomes for
the remaining fetuses and
the surrogacy contracts.
Also routinely container related clause
that restricts the surrogate's ability
to terminate the pregnancy without the
intended parents consent unless you faces
substantial harm from
continuing the pregnancy.
Should these promises to terminate
or not terminate pregnancies ever be
enforceable?
Should promise is determinate be
accorded more weight than promises not to
terminate for reasons suggested by the
casts and AC decisions should enforce it.
Borough should enforce the ability turn
on whether the surrogate or intended
parents would be biological.
Parents.
Few scholars think that a court would
ever order specific performance of the
surrogate's promises,
but the possibility of damages
is subject to differing views.
We have seen two different approaches
to frozen embryo cases in the two cases
we've discussed.
Cast versus casts treated agreements
about embryos is ordinary contracts where
courts should go along with the party's
expressed ex ante wishes a z versus BZ
on the other hand,
suggested that courts will not enforce
all agreements that commit parties to
future family relations because
these are against public policy.